[Music]
everybody I think I can kind of do a
small intro as you can probably tell by
the description I'm gonna try and focus
on some slightly different video
slightly different things this time
around I first want to look into some of
the animalistic mechanics and also kind
of show them off a little bit as well
and then I want to look into the
building pieces because even though I
know I spent a great deal of time
yesterday placing a lot of foliage and
looking at all kinds of scenery pieces I
don't really think I've had a good
enough look at actual building pieces so
that's something that I do definitely
want to take a look at I also want to
note that yesterday I did my stream
completely blind just because I thought
it would be interesting to get into the
game blind and see what I think of it
and see what I can discover with his
little knowledge as possible but in
hindsight that wasn't an entirely good
idea definitely messed up on a lot of
gameplay elements there so yesterday
I've gotten shown around the game quite
a bit so at least I'm a slightly more
knowledgeable person I mean I'm still a
total noob when it comes to this game I
only have about two hours experiencing
it
but that's got to count for something so
yeah let's get going yeah that's
actually turn on the screen everybody
welcome back to Planet zoo if I make the
impression like this is gonna be a very
quiet and laid-back stream I don't think
that's gonna be true and I sent out some
tweets and messages on discord etc
wherever I could
looking for recommendations and requests
what people wanted to see or what they
wanted to test or whatever so I have
this big list over here full of stuff
that I want to look into I might not get
to everything on the list but there's a
lot on here that might be interesting so
I'm first going to look at all kinds of
animal mechanics things that people have
been looking into things that I should
definitely look into myself because I
messed them up yesterday and then in the
second half of the stream I want to go
through the building pieces
I'm not going to build anything yet but
my idea is that today I want to get as
good of a look as possible of what's in
the game and yeah try to think about
that kind of grind my gears as I'm
sleeping tonight I suppose and then what
I'm coming back for the other streams
later this week on Friday and Saturday
maybe I'll be able to build some decent
stuff so yeah that's that's the idea
behind this stream so I'm gonna I don't
know I'm gonna put my phone somewhere
I'm not
where I should there's a lot of stuff on
this desk but yeah first of all we need
to make sure that animals aren't going
to escape again and I'm not entirely
sure what went wrong the last time
around but yeah I don't think any of the
enclosures were broken to begin with
it's just something that kind of
happened throughout the day I kind of
lost where the Bears are again this is
the bear enclosure think so right yeah
so it's not actually broken at the
moment but we'll get to that when we're
there I'm sure that some animals are
gonna escape at some point for now what
I find most interesting is the enclosure
stats I want to make sure that all of
the enclosures are actually good enough
for the animals so I'm gonna check all
of these guys so the game will tell you
a lot of information about the different
needs of the animals nutrition social
and habitat and enrichment obviously
nutrition is all about food social is
all relating to what kind of animals
you're putting together how large the
groups are etcetera habitats relates to
the kind of enclosure how large it is I
believe as well but you can get
different kinds of specificity specific
things to patch up if anything is wrong
and finally enrichments which relates to
food enrichment which isn't the same as
nutrition it's really just kind of
additional and finally toys which is the
one thing that's missing here and that's
I suppose why
that's-that's is too low so I'm just
going to go into habitats and look into
the enrichment items here and then you
can also filter it by certain species so
I'm gonna go into the grizzly bear
enrichment and then you get all the
stuff that grizzly bears might you need
so that's something that I'm looking to
hear and yeah at this point we can
pretty much place anything that we want
to depending on what we think would fit
into the enclosure typically I suppose
you want to put it somewhere where
people can actually notice the Bears
doing their thing
do you notice they already have this
[Music]
tough to see where the guests exactly
can see the Bears so here are the the
glass walls which are just one way so
the Bears won't be able to see the
guests so it's boys I'm just gonna put
this pendant on this plate here and
there we go that's fine it's not
something fixed I don't know how many
animals I'm gonna want to check here but
I'm just gonna want to make sure that
all of the animals are at least decent
in terms of stats so these guys need any
which means opossums
go back to that
let's see species and let's go to this
thing somewhere
I suppose was pretty good place and yeah
I guess the traps are good now okay they
need a lot of enrichment but again
that's the only issue it seems like in
this park in general enrichments seems
to be the largest issue so far and we'll
get a grand for ya that's probably good
so the cool thing about this grand ball
actually is that it completely obeys the
laws of physics I believe so yeah if you
plop it down somewhere it's actually
gonna fall down and the zebras might
pick it up at some point and carry it
around used to lift weights I suppose so
that'll be interesting I know that's
something really cool to see so oh there
we go we already have one so that's
super cool I'm just gonna drop down a
small barrel fear somewhere and go into
the animal camp which is also something
I didn't do last time and that was oh
got some beautiful hd pooping action ooh
anyway that's something that I should
have definitely done last time because
I've noticed that I know for some reason
the game just looks much better in an
animal can maybe it's just the
perspective I'm not sure it just looks
much more like the the screenshots that
they shared
so yeah it's super cool to see them go
around and actually pick this up
but yeah let's get out of this animal
coming today
I think we're all good in this enclosure
I'm just gonna move on to the Snow
Leopard I actually had to fix this guy
up the ladies I know is putting really
weird faces just in front of me here
it's very distracting
anyway we have some snow leopards in
here I have to fix this up a little bit
earlier and actually put the cooler in
their enclosure because they didn't have
any place to cool down but I think right
now this should be generally fine in
regards to that's what the habitat is
still not good enough if that's going to
change no so I guess we're gonna need
more cooling there are too many
questions I'm sorry there are so many
questions in the in the in the chats and
I want to try my best to get all of it
to all of the requests and the questions
that I got one over on Twitter and
Dysport so I can't answer everything but
if you really really want me to answer
something it helps to tank my name so it
pops out on my chest so I can get today
anyway we're gonna need to go to the
coolers reset the filters it easier I
put some coolers now here you also get
the heat map and this is something that
I didn't explain last time either but
this is actually really useful for
animal info this basically shows you all
kinds of information this is the
temperature so it shows us where the
cool temperatures are where the hot
temperatures are you can switch it to
water to see what's polluted what isn't
you need to do anything about that we
have electricity buildings negative
impact on guests this is something that
I might elaborate on later on but
backstage buildings will have a negative
effect on guests very much like park
attacks so that's something to keep in
mind you need to try to hide those as
much as possible and guests happiness is
one because it's all about balancing the
happiness of guests the animals and the
workers as well now I'm just gonna pop
some random coolers down here and
hopefully that's gonna pick this fix
this up a little bit terrain types also
course that's something to look into
I think the temperature thing actually
updates the knife because I saw that
change before I get an accrual
now the question is what kind of
temperatures this is kind ones so we go
to run environments to terrain I think
there should be one yeah here we go so
they need less long rows and more rocky
textures it's not something I should
look into so I'm gonna go out of the
heat map and waste much more walking
here and then gradually we should see it
becoming a bit better too much crossing
him they've really don't any grants fun
I mean that makes sense I mean these
guys live all the way up in the
mountains and the rocks but yeah there
we go that's perfect
so I know I ignored the animals last
time but this is this is me trying to
make up for it or by trying to actually
run this through decently this time
around now this guy is floating whatever
they're doing just a reminder this is an
alpha build and I've seen some stuff go
wrong in this build that actually didn't
go wrong and some of the other bills
because I can't say much about this but
in Gamescom different areas they have
different bills of the game but
something to keep in mind for sure oh I
didn't want to books this guy
I love that you could go into the animal
can while they're boxed but that's not
what I try to do anyway should be fine
anyway I just realized that I call it a
guide of all time but it's a human I'm
sorry about that
can we see all the animals and yeah like
this I love the ears well you wear them
at the meet up I don't think so I stole
those tiger ears yesterday and I kept
them with me the whole day and the whole
night even I slept with him no not quite
there but she was really upset about
that so I'm gonna have to give these
back to bow as soon as I'm done anyway
yeah I can show all of the animals but
the only animals that we can see now I
remember
geek ISM you made a video saying that
you could probably get all of the
animals in sandbox mode which I think
we'll probably be true but if we go to
animal trading here the list is limited
we don't have all of the animals in the
game so yeah this is still based on the
whole trading system so I don't think we
can get all of the animals in this map
and I'm not sure what that means because
I thought this is like a sandbox map but
maybe it's not entirely sandbox or maybe
I'm just missing something in which case
I'm sorry about that but I haven't found
a way to see all the animals that are in
the game in this build of the game at
least because everything
probably locked down to some extent I
love su tycoons this game have the same
fight I have to be completely honest I
haven't played zoo tycoon since my
childhood
so my view on this is like completely
rose-colored for me it does but then
again I'm not a zoo tycoon expert can
you name a penguin Megatron can you name
the reason why that's a penguin name I'm
not sure I personally I like it when
animals in zoos have very thematic names
depending on the country where they're
from or where they donated from or the
zoo or whatever they are traded with
somebody wanted to look into the hippo
is that's something that I've got on my
list here actually but first I gotta say
that lease okay needs more social
whenever it is social roof needs to be
part of logic group so we want to treat
use okay right we should definitely get
more hippos into this
have a chance probably and we need to
get some fluid enrichments let's see
right so I'm gonna they built this my
species again this is not something you
have to do I suppose once you play the
game enough I think you're probably
gonna get exactly what animals need what
items but for now I have no idea so I'm
just gonna use this to count me along
I'll just play CC I'm not gonna be too
worried oh I thought that was gonna look
really bad but it actually automatically
terraformed around it to make it a place
that's it anyway suppose no that's not
enough apparently
oh right I'm in food I'm an idiot I'm
sorry guys I need to get some food
enrichment so I'm just gonna put they're
all feeder somewhere and get rid of this
because we don't really need him and
then I think it should be fine but yeah
somebody wanted me to look at the hippos
from the guests view which is in here so
you can actually see them under water
but this water is very filthy actually
like I think it could be a bit cleaner
I'm not sure so I'm gonna check the heat
map actually on that but it looks like
there's room for improvement here oh no
looks like it's actually cleaning up I
wonder if we have any actually doesn't
seem that way but this is the filtration
system building over here so that's why
that's when it's just it just looks like
that I suppose I want to give a quick
shout out to Matthew Florian's who
worked on the sound of this game and he
really wanted me to point this out and I
hope you guys can hear this as soon as
you go underwater the sound changes and
it all becomes very subtly faded so it's
still very much the same sounds but you
can hear that it's it's very different
and it's very much like cut off to low
frequencies it's pretty cool
could you give birth to baby snow
leopards that's a really good point
another one of my things on the list was
to try the breathing mechanic but I
actually dismissed that because I have
no idea how breathing actually works
this is one of the few things that I
haven't looked into outside of the
street at all so yeah I have no idea
it's weird I have no idea how to fix
that actually it might be because I just
changed the cursor settings before I
went on because the sensitivity was
really high and I I don't I don't know I
have my sensitivity kind of low usually
try to get at least advance
so I actually shifted but since fifty
maybe that's the issue I don't know but
yeah how do we I think honestly you just
have to get lucky have a male and a
female and just have lucky you just have
to be lucky for them to get it on
produce offspring let's dance
I'm not sure if anyone in the chat can
correct me on this somehow if anybody
somehow knows more than I do but that's
as far as I know I also know that they
just they just kind of poop into
existence so that's something you don't
really have a whole like pregnant well
they got pregnant and all that but you
don't really have a mission through and
I believe oh right there's just a few
more any closure isn't there I'm gonna
need to check the enclosure oh I'm one
of the snow leopards walls looks damaged
I didn't know that
into that
so what what would that be how can I
check which of the walls will be damaged
I honestly have no idea
anyway yeah there's this one it's no
level in here son I'm gonna buy another
one I'm gonna buy a meal and see if they
get it on but I doubt they will by the
end of this dream but we just so happen
to have a male snow leopard here and
something to keep in mind as well I
don't know what these leaves me I've
seen a lot of people ask about this and
I forgot to ask this so maybe I'll get
to that after this dream but I've seen
so many people ask questions about this
I'm not entirely sure at some form of
currency the metals etc regardless are
the appeal rating now this will depend
for animal and also yeah per animal
specifically and for species but yeah
five thousand is wider I okay all right
[Music]
anyway we're gonna buy this mail and
send it to the zoo and put them down
over here and then there will get
delivered sometime soon
let's see if they actually make ladies
there are no water physics in this game
but the water is volumetric which is a
word that's been dropped a lot of times
but I can actually show something really
interesting this was also on my list so
let's square that off Rudy and I just
spent some time playing the game here in
the demo zone and we just covered
something really really cool that I am
super hyped about so you can place a
bunch of fences and make a little space
this will be enough I'm just gonna close
this anyway and then if you go to the
terrain tools this worked on the bill
that we played I don't know yeah there
you go okay it's totally glitching out
so that's something to look into but you
can place water inside the fences
which is super cool we were already
brainstorming that you can make little
penguin enclosures with this where the
water just kind of reaches up to the
fence or how even make fountains like
non enclosure related things around
paths and kind of spruce up the zoo in
this way I should probably look into
this because this looks bit weird
doesn't it and you can also edit
different barriers so I'm just gonna
edit this barrier here and there are all
kinds of options for these barriers that
I didn't look into on the last stream so
you can
well here's the thing also that I should
mention on stream we were unable to get
this to work like we're unable to select
all of the barriers were unable to erase
them and lower them and broody had this
in a stream as well and he just kind of
quietly shuffled that issue away but on
the demo pcs here this actually works so
this is something that's definitely
related to this build of the game so I
can't true it off because in this
specific built that we're streaming on a
doesn't work but on the final game it's
there and on all of the other builds
here it works you can just select all of
the pencils you can raise them lower
them turn the whole thing into a
different type of things you can even
grab the entire fence structure and move
it somewhere else which is if I'm ever
randomly waving of just waving that
people were passing by it but yeah that
is super cool you can change the
textures that's something that works
here actually and there's all kinds of
things that you can change about this
you can add a window in here in that
build you can also change the height etc
of the window there are all kinds of
really cool settings related to the
fences but in this build of the game
they don't seem to work that well this
is something to really look forward at
least personally I think this is one of
like my favorites positive surprises
that I didn't know about before I came
here but the enclosure walls are
insanely flexible you can do so much
with these you can even use them as long
enclosure related things you can really
build things out of these and make them
it's super cool how close can you get to
the terrain kept the terrain to the wall
and us to make nice terrorist areas
that's pretty good question it's
something I could look into also as you
noticed as soon as you put the rudder in
the texture of the whole area changed it
so that's also quite cool so you always
get decent-looking what our arrogance
but yeah I'll look into the parts of it
I I'm sorry if I'm kind of all over the
place I'm just kind of trying to respond
to the chat here and also to the
requests that occurred earlier I've had
a request also to look into the parts so
this is also a good thing to look into
we have well the course who gets the
parts the this one is just a standard
concrete one this one it's just like the
assembly looking textures of wooden
parts this is a brick one yeah there we
go
and finally another big one as you can
see it works very much like planet
coasters past although you do see that
the terrain also changes which is
different but I have no idea how it
interacts with terrain honestly the
terrain tours also changed a lot and I
haven't used it myself yet so that's
something to mess around later but yeah
it looks to be about the same as with
planet coaster there's a certain area
around the path where it will remain at
the same Heights
and it's not so much that you can change
Monday that's something to keep in mind
I don't think path work will
specifically be much easier or harder I
think they just changed some slight
things about it maybe look maybe make
them look a bit better in some sort of
ways but overall it seems to be exactly
the same as planet coaster we also have
cute paths which is two parts with the
exact same textures as planet coasters
original cues and finally the paths for
the employees which will be quite
important in hiding the employee areas
from the guests because they won't like
seeing that and they all have the same
texture even if they have slightly
different colors so that's something
that you can easily can you tell me how
big the map is it's really hard to tell
but you can see there's a border here so
yeah but if i zoom out it's difficult to
tell but it's it is somewhere around
here where I'm moving the cursor I know
that the cursor is it's about as big as
this part looks like the park is mostly
lengthy but yeah this is definitely the
full length and then the entrance areas
using up a lot of the other width of the
map as one it's completely square just
like planet coaster maps that said this
is just one park and just like a planet
coaster we do know that our different
sizes of maps so maybe there's something
like that as well I don't know anything
about my size I have to say aside from
what we're seeing new although I have a
suspicion that this is not going to be
the largest map science but I'm not sure
can you open and close the big doors by
hand so that they were in place I'm not
sure I might look into that later
[Music]
oh good point I'll go back
so far I don't have any issues with the
animals yet so that's good this other
different landscape backgrounds I don't
know if I'm allowed to say that actually
take that as you may but actually now
we've already seen different backgrounds
I think many of the things that puts you
in sho'nuff so yeah but other things
that I need to look into
I think the sandbox won't be flights by
the fluence I think it'll be a little
bit like Planet ghost like there might
be something to that's just completely
guessing no other stuff fixed it
oh that's awesome actually so if you
have enough stuff you can actually avert
catastrophe anymore can you manually
move animals yes
very simply you just grab them and click
on move and put them where you want to
find video here's the move button if you
want to be like some of the other
streamers that ever straighten this game
so far you can definitely put some
animals together that should not belong
together
I think it's textured one way for the
Snow Leopard I sure hope so eventually
because this this one way windows oh
it's not actually hmm that might be
something to change I don't know if the
snow leopards minded specifically but it
does help to have one way glance for a
lot of animals I've heard or at least
I've been told because some animals
might get anxious a lot of people are
watching them so I've definitely been
recommended to use the one-way glass in
certain 60-hour certain situations yeah
I didn't actually check all of the
animals events either something I still
want to do I think the hippos they were
totally fine what's in here again we
can't see yes
oh this was the Lions just sitting the
boundary needs to be repaired but I
think some people are doing that right
now they're just out there chillin with
the Lions all right but I do wonder if
this is all ok that's actually
tonight they just need more enrichment
how is lighting at night there's a lot
of question construction options and
building pieces that's something that I
want to go into into the second part
this videos that's something that I'll
try one five minutes from now a giant
scary spider try to remember that
and there are guests work actually I was
just talking with Rudy that it'd be
super cool to see if we can have guests
enter certain enclosures this would be
really cool for certain a thing closures
of things like that well we'll see about
that
anyway I'm just gonna normal enrichment
that is reset
should be oh no wait it's food
enrichment that's the issue
and that thing is gonna start warming
down we do oh that's really cool
I can't look into waterfalls it's not in
this build unfortunately performance
it's really hard to tell I'm playing
this on a really beasty computer so no
idea
the parks rain I don't think we have on
right camera yes yeah we can't look at
that
what were some of the other things that
I was gonna have to look into yeah
guests doors
ix mode
and I'll quickly visit the spider let's
see what that Goliath is Philippe
Philippe it's in here that's a really
nice exhibit
[Music]
maybe I'm just missing something really
obvious again everybody I'm in cm well
we have an animal camp so okay that's
just the simple cam on the exhibit never
mind
sorry about that I'll quickly trying
night mode because there is also another
thing that I've been wanting to look
into and that is other the lights look
move to nights so these are all the
lights
it's alright enough I think
somebody in the chat with a really cool
thanks Josefa giant bird you are as big
as the jaws of a leopard and closures
within enclosures yeah I think that's
possible actually if for some reason you
want to do that but spiders usually on
the floor of the Train
see that them
bring it back today
that's a harsh transition
still don't see him he is in here right
yeah
I don't know if anyone sees it then we
can call it out in the chat but I have
no idea Ryan if you want to see the
trees and foliage I recommend checking
out my sweet bean yesterday it's on my
youtube channel at the moment because I
checked out pretty much all of the trees
and foliage in there anyway it's nearly
30 I want to check on some of the last
animals just to make sure that their
welfare is okay maybe it's not a few
more staff members just to make sure
that white is not going to break down
while I check out the filming elements
issue here no space well I'm really
sorry but that's not something I can
easily fix that's something that really
kind of needs to be all right from the
get-go but
I will add some enrichment in their
pistons another issue isn't it
enrichments food yeah playthings
as it possible to build something like
the a patrol with roaming animals that's
exactly what I was thinking my video I
have no idea once they definitely want
to test the few things because I think
would be super cool it would be so nice
to have especially with some animals
that you can realistically you know
considering animal and guest welfare
realistically have around the guests it
would be super cool its have the mocha
man I was actually a little bit
disappointed that the the peafowl which
thinks how around here isn't just really
roaming like they put a fence around
these edges as well just to make this an
enclosure like I'll fight the guys
they're in here some but yeah it would
be cool to just have people be able to
walk through these enclosures like this
it's the headset on your ears that's the
one thing that I've always wondered
there are so many pictures of like cat
girls with the headset on their human
ears this doesn't make any sense
sight no sight no I'm not a cat girl
anymore I was yesterday but I've
transitioned into a wolf that's that's
what I am now this is my life now will
there be codes like in Glencoe there
will be so I've heard that we have
techid cam and I haven't tried it myself
yet but this guy who is named after a
country oh we can't rename him that's a
shame and I think we can rename him in
this game or in this specific demo but
I've heard that tattooed camp is a thing
that's super cool and I think anybody
has tried it on streem yet so maybe just
doesn't work in this build but I
participated could use [ __ ] releasing
a couple of wolves to give them more
space yeah I guess that would be the
ethical thing to do wouldn't it I don't
know if I want to do that staff can be
oh yeah that's a good point
sorry I never remember I should look
into stuff so
I'm gonna rename somebody make them take
it well that didn't work I've heard from
other people that it
I'm sorry dude you're just going to be a
full ticket
[Music]
anyway I've heard it's a thing I'm sorry
I can't show it off right here maybe I
look insulated right so know what this
guy is oh that's not a stock man no
that's just oh that is a security guard
yeah right
he has that security guy walk to it all
right
oh there we go all right now we're stuck
in a wall so that's not ideal but it's a
thing that's awesome
all right so we confirm that anyway I
just want to quickly run through a
couple of things that I might be able to
quickly see about the animals before I
move on to the building thesis which I
really want to see animals reacting to
weather changes that's something that I
want to show off for sure I don't know
where we could best check that but let's
make it snow these poor guys are not
used to snow at all so
let's just use my my total omniscient
powers to make it snow here and
fast-forward and if all goes well they
should be looking for shelter right yeah
there we go
so they're all running to the shelters
now just because it's the moment is that
snow and what you also notice is that
the temperature is rapidly declining
here and if I speed this up a little bit
in this biome it should be able to go
below zero degrees or yeah one degree
Celsius and then you can start seeing
the snow stay on the ground what's also
interesting is that we have the heaters
around here so the snow doesn't stay on
the ground good around the heaters but
anywhere else where it's cold enough
where it's around the freezing point or
lower snow will stay yeah you can over
here you can see around the water you
have like a slightly different texture
on this note
likely not the same way it's absolutely
awesome we have shark out here who is an
absolute MATLAB just grazes through the
snow whatever but yeah that's really
cool I love the weather effects in
general I'm gonna be easy on these I'm
gonna make it summer together you can
you build a new and closer to the wall I
don't think I have enough time for that
I'm sorry maybe something I can see
later and I want to speed it up snow and
you can actually see the snow sticking
around as well certain areas especially
one here here where I put the coolers
the snow sticks around longer I didn't
even know that but that's super cool
literally yeah that's really nice you
can slowly see it melting away as well
are these guys getting it on I don't
know that looks like some very sexy
action over here
hmm it's gonna - that animal can get a
close-up of this
oh wait I'm still in sped-up mode that's
a bit weird anyway maybe they'll get it
on Monday I see I see a romance or
something here can animals interact with
many manually placed vegetation yeah I
definitely do
I don't think we have any interesting
climbers in this map but they definitely
interact with vegetation so that'll be
really interesting in fact the thing is
and this is something that I wanted to
show off as well this is one of my
animal things that I wanted to talk
about in habitats we have actually not
inhabits there we go
we have the claimable things so you can
use these logs and build stuff out if
it's to Cuba Mike to Circus and then put
on English stuff as well I think you can
very easily build your own wooden
structures
support them so that's really
interesting and really cool definitely a
really cool feature in the game
I know these hippos are not going to
climb on these but I just want to show
this off all right so animals that can
climb on these were climb of these but I
don't think it's anything related to the
actual object the only point is that
this will add climb aboard features into
the enclosure which is good for the
animal welfare but animals will be able
to climb anything so if you put rockwork
up in an enclosure and build it in such
a way that they can use it to climb over
the enclosure walls they just might
literally it seems like I mean I haven't
seen animals play with everything but it
seems like animals will interact with
any objects like it's an actual physical
object
can you change how quickly slowly
animals age in the settings menu I have
no idea about that actually we don't
have a settings menu in here which is
interesting doesn't the water freeze
maybe at some point I guess I didn't
stick around for a long enough to see
that
but yeah we've seen animals interact
with water we've seen all kinds of other
interesting things somebody wanted to
see inside the fence building which is I
suppose the last thing that I look into
before I look into the building pieces
because I really want to get to that as
well I'm just gonna turn on the heat map
to see where exactly the gerlichs are
because I'll find out what the Fed
building is Oh God
so this is actually it's probably one of
these rights Research Center star Center
yes the best so this is one of the most
detailed interiors I think I switch it
to people it is daytime right okay
there's a zebra there
this is relocating to designation
nonsense so I don't know exactly how
this works but you can go inside and you
can see what they're doing and there we
go
Madonna is getting relocated right now
so yeah that's what that looks like
sorry if that was just a really quick
overview but I really want to move into
some of the construction elements but is
that something that I didn't end up
looking at yesterday and it's something
that I personally really want to see and
I want to see as much of these as
possible there are some other building
elements that I want to get into I think
that before metal water which is quite
important I think weather and buildings
is also something I want to look into so
just in case I forget
feel free to remind me and we've seen a
lot of other things that were on my list
anyway before I go into the buildings
though I just quickly want to show off
the terrain tools they are completely
different from planet coaster at least
some of them are these are all very
similar we have poor to bring upwards we
can change the intensity of setting we
can actually
painting at the same time that's that's
a useful new feature what is this my
paint style is currently under cursor
okay that's also really cool but I'm
just gonna change the pact across here
those are people dabbing at me sorry I
had to that back and you have like
specific shapes over here they can look
into
Oh Johnny what's is looking at me at the
moment that's really cool
he's from Paul to you just in case you
didn't know wait how does this work
exactly
oh these tools I suppose don't work I do
oh that's it oh no there we go so you
can make all kinds of weird shapes with
these as well and then we have the train
text I'm just gonna undo all that mess
everybody keeps stabbing at me I'm sorry
guys I have to do it anyway construction
we're finally getting to buildings let's
see what we haven't you I really need to
know chimps can escape through rocks and
trees I am pretty sure they can I
haven't seen them do this I can't
confirm it but they can definitely
probably climb trees and all of that
stuff let's see
breathe block wall we're getting some
all ta I've been hearing I actually
didn't know that that's what that means
that song title was explained to me now
asphalt roof that's interesting this
will be actually really good for
backstage buildings and things like that
we have the ATM bellow sign from planet
coaster I gotta say these bricks look
really good the textures on them are
amazing the way that they interact with
the lighting as well it's absolutely
beautiful that's really one of this
different brick wall a lot of these are
not recoverable and I've seen some
different discussions about that I think
it's actually not too bad very typically
if you have recolor ball items you can't
quite get the textures to be as like the
textures will very often have a single
color looks to them as well it's really
hard to describe it but it's something
back from even rollercoaster tycoon 3 a
lot of the the best-looking pieces were
not recoverable just to have more
variety of color in the standard
textures so I know that's something to
keep in mind but there will be different
items that are recolor well there are
just some that are and some the comments
so this is all the brick wall pieces all
of the piece shapes are the same as in
Planet goes through so that's something
that we can easily adjust to this is
awesome we get lots of different detail
pieces for
somebody just somebody just subscribe to
me right in front of me like showing me
the subscribe button thanks for
subscribing anyway we get lots of
different detail pieces so we can really
detail like classical buildings and
things like that with these it just want
to quickly rotate them get them in their
rights kind of wait is this yeah this is
fine so you can really build your own
pediments with these you can built like
classical buildings with custom
pediments and all of that stuff that's
awesome okay I'm gonna switch back I'm
gonna stop the mining to surface we have
a whole bunch of blocks these are new
really nice I like that a classic clock
tower aspire I always love a good spire
that's awesome and even with a long
thing added to them you have two spires
already three spires that's nice
a decorative brick by brick arch that's
super useful I can't play sports to the
beamers and look at the climb on it I'm
gonna look into the building stuff first
but I can assure you they will well I
can't say 100% sure I haven't seen them
do it but I'm pretty sure they do that's
something that I might get back to in a
later stream as well for now I really
want to see all of the building pieces
some beautiful classical doors these go
really well with the other pieces that
we've seen so far
canopy's these are really beautiful but
also standalone door which is really
useful if you want to build your own
frame around it that's really good
I'm pretty sure it's getting really
annoying that everything's kind of
tilted so I'm gonna turn on angle snap
and make this thing straight right this
is an extra door so you can really
customize quite a bit about this this is
really good very promising so far this
is a beautiful fence
god I love fence long border limestone
fans here are some of the lanterns
anybody who's interested in building
stuff this is your time to screenshot
things I'm sure you're already doing
that but here's just a reminder
screenshots and share that stuff around
man
we have window boxes that's really good
there are so many flowers and stuff like
that that you can fill these with
episodio sculpture on behalf of all the
Dutch people I am sorry for making the
Dodos extinct that was one of the most
grave mistakes we've ever made as a
nation and we we've done some terrible
things
here's a classical shop canopy very much
like the canopies that we've seen in
planet coaster but these are the ones
generic ad-lib at least this one is this
recolor of all it is okay perfect so
that is super useful we have some vents
that's nice
classical wall bracket and this is the
kind of piece that makes me super hyped
it's a tiny little piece but it's it's
really beautiful and it's the kind of
thing that you
can infinitely expand upon and build
your own things with these are the kind
of fences that you can put on bridges
and on all kinds of ballast trades and
things like that that is beautiful
that's really awesome really happy with
that as well
what else do we have in here a weather
vane I'm glad that that's there and a
different weather vane as well we don't
really have a usual weather vane but I
don't know I like this one too much
so that's okay although it would be cool
to see an actual clock on one of these
let me see how is the scale that's a
really good question I have no idea how
we can compare things maybe I should go
to some guests so we can kind of compare
what this skill on some of these things
are yeah so let's see yeah this bracket
really is tiny and these lights
everything seems to be well up to scale
we have a tree cage that's awesome
killer that's really nice I really I
approve of that pre drinking fountains
science for restaurants and things like
that that's really useful all kinds of
different windows I mean the scale
overall it seems to be better than
planet coaster it's hard to tell and of
course this is a large window yes
okay this this is a huge window but
notice the skill seems really good yeah
when you compare it to planet coaster
the items to do seem smaller
yeah there's no Archer to check the
scale which is a bit disappointing isn't
it
let's see other restaurants hotels in
the game there are but I'm just gonna
quickly go over to this piece they are
pretty much the same as the planet
Kosovo
so we get all of the good brands that we
know by now go P hoc squad actually yeah
all of them Greeks somebody asks if
there's cheap beef in the game and I
believe there is it is foxy coffee
that's really cool a cheap beef is here
but we don't get the mascots ugly at
least we haven't seen it so far
who knows fits in the final game but I
mean mascots aren't much of a zoo thing
anyway so I wouldn't mind not having
those but we do have the cheap beef shop
which is nice to see oh god now we're
gonna scroll back to where I was how far
ahead was I
okay so what else do we have how much
time do I have left 13 minutes all right
let's keep going
I really have to end this dream in 30
minutes because somebody is coming on
right after me there is no leeway here
so I'm gonna have to go through this as
fast as I can while also paying
attention to every single item let's see
it's oh god I think that's something how
I'm gonna miss him this stream I'm sorry
but I'll try to try to keep note of what
I couldn't look at in this stream and
I'll try to come back in it to it in the
next stream these streams and an hour is
just too short to look at everything
that you want to look at I'm trying my
best to go through this as quickly as
possible we have copper roots they look
really this look really awesome not
recoverable but again for this kind of
texture I think that's okay
it'll be difficult to get this level of
detail and with that plus what kind of
color are you gonna make copper anyway
unless it's completely new of course oh
these look really good god I like that
stone texture on this that's also can
definitely build some really cool like
castles or ruins or something like that
even for animal enclosures something
like PI V dies in Belgium for instance I
think they've got a lot of things that
kind of have the same look to them
here's all the atrium pieces I'm not
going to put too much attention into
these but as you can see they are very
flexible in all kinds of dome pieces and
things like that so yeah we can even
build beautiful glass domes in different
shapes and sizes with these that's
really awesome the amount of flexibility
you get with these glass pieces also
these could be really useful for giant
windows you can put an arch piece around
that and yeah that'll be beautiful are
there small wooden pieces it's something
that we'll see in a minute I suppose I'm
just going through the list here and we
have modern glass roofs as well so we
have two different types of glass here
we have straight glass panel which we
can move I believe yeah there we go so
that's awesome if you want to make
custom windows anything like that
this would be a really useful morg
laughs oh god there are so many glass
pieces I think they they took the tip
from Planet coaster that people really
like glass pieces here's a glass opaque
wall so if you want to make like a
building that's glass on the outside but
not see horizontal planks not sure how
much I like these actually they look
monic honestly they look more like metal
sheets moves maybe it's just the
lighting change that a little bit
nobody seems that way then we have this
very lights wouldn't x2 that's a really
cool text to see this is the kind of
thing that you would never be able to
achieve with recolor worldwar pieces
those just too much variations in text
do lots of fountains I've briefly looked
into that earlier but yeah you'll
definitely be able to make custom
fountains with all kinds of scenery
items on them these are really useful
for all of the lanterns and the planters
and all the detailed items you can put
on top of these pedestal items
why are some items wrong aligned and
must be rotated after the selection I
think it's probably to do that these
items are typically stuck onto or
usually what you'll see is that for
instance lanterns will have different
rotation than these pieces for instance
because their standard rotation should
be different like you're attaching them
attaching them on a different plane but
we are really happy to see these
planters and things like that these
limestone walls be quite flexible as
well and then we have the kind of rustic
wooden log walls or useful for a variety
of themes I'd say let's see what else do
we have in here
it's a metal plant walls see this looks
very similar to that little groove so I
don't know I'm not sure what's up
okay there is so much stuff in here what
is this I'd call that sheet metal I'll
take it texture and a painted brick wall
oh that is awesome
that slightly painted brick look that's
really nice I wasn't expecting that but
that's nice planter and this one I would
assume is to be colorable yeah there we
go so this is a texture that's very much
with color but I find this red to be a
bit too bright so you can definitely
shifted to different shade the exact
same coloring system from Planet coaster
is banks so you can pretty much change
this to any shade you like depending on
your scenery so that's pretty cool what
is your goal to built in the screen I'm
not building anything yet I want to see
all of the pieces that are in the game
so that next dream I can have an idea of
what's here I can start thinking about
what I want to build upstream and then
hopefully come back and see what I can
actually build also I know that there
are a lot of people who are watching
this just screen showing everything
trying to know what exactly is in the
game so I'm trying as much as possible
to show off all of the different scenery
elements in the game because I'm not
entirely sure if anybody else is going
to quite do that so I just want to make
sure that well everybody's up to speed
as to what you can do in the game see me
wise as well this is a gutter ooh that's
really cool that's it that's an element
of detail that I was not expecting I do
really cool realistic and they have so
many pieces point as well there's some
hanging laps that's really nice
especially for modern interiors or non
modern anyway it doesn't really matter
too much the information side which is
very thematic I like that and also some
load pieces so if you want to build
really really large structures out of
logs and then this will be useful and
then this is a good summary piece I'd
say here are the basic shapes we know
what all of those are I think these are
the exact same basic shapes as we have
in planet coaster as well do you have
access to the pool game are you
restricted I'm restricted in some ways
and also this is a demo build so not
everything is in the game yet not
everything works either there are some
bugs and glitches to work out and we
have the same ropes coming back from
planet coaster although it looks like it
was slightly different texture this time
is a model and also different sign
pieces with
eggs what is that oh no that's custom
tanks are back that's really cool I
didn't notice that before I thought it
was something like the science but this
one has edible text so you can put your
own text limits as we expect let's
quickly see how that looks
that's not how you spell hello but I
guess it shows just how it works so yeah
we got that how much have we left six
minutes all right that's yeah we can
make our way through the rest of this
scenery elements some science should be
useful to show what enclosures are aware
that's a really fun parts scenery
building any bits of flowers which you
can decorate all kinds of things with I
love flowers you might be able to tell
so that's really nice to see it's
finally gutters with rain oh my god
that's an amazing idea I don't think I
have enough time for it now but
definitely tomorrow might be if you see
me again if you checking back in on some
of the other streams I'm gonna try to
remember that for when I do build a
building because it would be awesome to
see that in motion because I definitely
remember the rain trickling down on the
sides of the roofs it would be so cool
to see it fall into the gutters that's
awesome I'm sure that the gutters will
at the very least you'll see the rain
will fall into the gutters which will be
awesome
some plaster pillars that's super useful
I hope we have some foundation pieces
for these although I guess some of the
earlier decoration pieces that are
sprawled through you can probably use
them as foundations for these clothes I
have to say though I haven't seen any
Corinthian or Union flops with these
pillows so that would be cool to see as
well all those in English actually but
I'm sure you know what I mean oh and
here are the special effects somebody
asked about that earlier well there you
go
we do have a special effect we get dirt
blowing we get fountains of course
different jets in here actually
we have mists we have all different
forms of mist smoke bursts that'll be
quite useful oh god there's a lot I'm
gonna skip through a few of these
because these will probably be quite
similar to planet coaster snow blowing
that's really cool yeah and here the
Jets so these will be really useful for
regular fountains what else and we have
the splashes making a comic as well
letters it's a nice little scenery
elements stone brick wall it looks quite
nice they're not reusing they're barely
using any textures from Planet coaster
or none at all I know that some of the a
lot of the pieces will have to save
models but all of the textures look
different so that's really cool to see
as well some critical plank cause some
wooden plank walls and we all bear oh
and finally some would have ghosts thank
God we have winter coats can we recover
these though can't recolor them that's a
bit of a bummer I have to be honest
you can do anything with that also I
have to say I don't think that this will
be all of the scenery in the final game
yet but I I'm not too sure about that
but I think I've heard some stuff going
around about its different objects as
well Plus this is an early build of the
game still so who knows what we'll see I
didn't look at this classic arts before
but that looks really cool there's just
so many little little Victorian items
that you can make really nice buildings
with the new
[Music]
yeah it's probably pronounced ionic
isn't it
Doric ionic Corinthian yeah I mostly
like ionic and Corinthian for obvious
reasons I suppose they're just the most
fancy if you're looking cute eh yeah
well thank you yeah so that's all of the
scenery I'm really running out of time I
have two more minutes I don't know what
I'm gonna do with that finally let's
look at the facilities I haven't looked
at those letters quickly scroll through
these quickly opponents there are all
the different buildings
feel free to screenshot if you're
interested in specifically these things
we have solar panels transformers water
treatment plants and wind turbines very
modern wind turbines it's really cool
the difference the security camera from
planet coaster makes comic let's see if
we can get into that and use it to make
cinematic shots we can't yet but maybe
we can in the final game and picnic
benches
and finally exhibits education board
something to keep in mind there are
educational speakers Matthew Florian's
wanted me to say this he wanted me to go
into the bear the bear enclosure where's
that again because you'll have speakers
explaining all kinds of educational
details about the different animals oh
yeah there we go
it's in blank oh so it's hard to tell
exactly what they're saying I'm sure
game stands no it's exactly what they're
talking about but yeah that's really
cool you'll have all kinds of
educational stuff as well that you can
use our final notes let's just take the
last tab here are the transport rice and
we don't have these available just yet
viewing but we have education boards
conservation boards so they're making
this in the whole debate about zoos
being ethical at least they are throwing
this in here so there will be a sort of
conservation angle where
you know there's a lot of discussions
about the ethics of having zoos but at
the very least it's important in
conservation issues and education with
people so I think that's a really good
touch anyway it's exactly time I don't
know exactly what time it is it's
exactly 3:00 the time of these computers
is America anyway I like to thank you
guys for watching it's been a really
great stream I'm so glad that I've been
able to look into other things that I've
wanted there are still a few things on
my list that I want to look into if you
have anything that you want me to look
into on my next stream be sure to hit me
up on Twitter
it's just silver as well also in the
discord for planets ooh and in a bunch
of other discourse as well so yeah
anywhere you can hit me up if you really
want to let me show something and yeah
thank you guys for watching I hope you
guys have a nice day and I'm gonna give
space to the other streamer I don't know
exactly who they are but that will be
plenty of other teammates today anyway
one more time thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you next time on
Friday bye-bye everybody
that's the wrong I'll just get a
transition out there we go